senator Doug Jones made history when he
became the first Democrat to win a US
Senate seat in Alabama in 25 years
before that as a US Attorney Jones
focused on writing a historic wrong the
unsolved 1963 bombing of the 16th Street
Baptist Church in Birmingham for black
girls Addie Mae Collins Denise McNair
Carol Robertson and Cynthia Wesley were
killed when they were getting ready for
church
the first bomber was convicted in 1977
later nearly 40 years after the attack
Jones won the conviction of two more
bombers in 2001 and 2002 he writes about
the transformational process in his new
book bending towards justice the
Birmingham church bombing that changed
the course of civil rights senator
welcome thank you all right as we talked
about to you earlier our thoughts are
with you and of course the people of
Alabama with those terrible well I
appreciate that very much we're very
strong and I know those first responders
and folks are responding appropriately
and everything is going to go well let
me ask you about this book you were 9
years old when this bombing took place
why did it stick with you for that well
you know I think the whole civil rights
movement sticks with folks especially in
the south and in Alabama and as you
learn and you see more the civil rights
this bombing was kind of swept under the
carpet for so long and then it came up
and then I sat through those classes and
through that first trial and it just
stays with you forever let me talk to
you about that tension because some
people say let it let the pastor in the
past we've moved on why are you picking
at this well because I think you have to
understand what happened in order to try
to prevent things from the in the future
you know we're unfortunately seeing a
lot of hate-filled rhetoric these days
and we're seeing more hate crimes and I
think when people see this and we keep
it to the front and people understand
we can prevent things from going on in
the future you also said that you're a
white southerner where race was not
discussed in your house as a little boy
race was just something that was is but
it was not discussed correct it was just
you know we look it was a segregated
Society
I was very sheltered we were not a
family of haters by any stretch at all
but when they going to discuss but when
the Klan did this this act this horrible
act you said that changed the game
because it was sort of an unwritten rule
that you don't attack or her child
that's true and we had had so many
bombings in Birmingham but the fact is I
don't know one had been
even hurt much less kill and near more
now have four innocent little children
they weren't part of the movement they
were kids going to a worship service
that changed everything it woke up the
conscience of America I think when these
children died and the conscience of a
Congress and a president the title of
your book reminds us of something very
hopeful that quote and that is that the
arc of history is long but it in store
justice bends towards justice always
that was a phrase certainly that
President Barack Obama used many times
where are we now do you think as a
former prosecutor on these crimes where
are we in terms of is racism getting
worse or we hear more about it I think
we hear more about it I think it's been
the below the surface but we hear more
about it and what I'm what worries me
more is the social media and we are all
in our silos we only hear what we want
to hear and we talk what we want to talk
and that social media really I think
propagates a lot of race we also wonder
too if the attention is it because we're
saying this is wrong there's the
attention this is wrong
we're not prosecuting this person who
shot a black man is broadly not talking
about it or about it not talking about
it is wrong to in a very honest and
straightforward way we've seen
Charlotte's what we've seen South
Carolina we've seen Pittsburgh it's not
just black and white anymore
it is also race its religion its gender
its nationality and so we've got to have
more dialogues about this I think in
this case so we need to re-evaluate how
it's taught in our schools given as you
said the role of social media and the
fact that this continues to dominate
headlines absolutely I really think that
if we just learn more about the civil
rights movement even when we were
selecting a jury there were young
african-american kids it really didn't
know they really didn't appreciate and
fully understand dr. King and his legacy
I think we need to teach more about what
happened and just do it unvarnished you
know let the good and the bad come out
so that people can understand we can
only go forward if we learn from the
lesson see that's why I think your book
is so important because you really take
us inside the court cases
Chambliss you said was a horrible
horrible man nobody liked him that he
was a weird dude that he was just evil
that even his own family turned on here
right but the two that you prosecuted
Blanton and cherry tell us about the two
of them and how you actually went to see
Blanton in prison twice to say okay come
on totally different gods Jerry used to
run his mouth all the time you would
always lie but he made it mission
over the years and that's what really
helped us get the conviction his
admissions lanten was more of a recluse
he stayed to himself and we had to put
the pieces of the puzzle together and
there was a tape recording that we were
able to find of a discussion with him
and his wife in which he admitted I went
to see Blanton twice in prison to try to
give him an opportunity I think is why
do you think that was important well
because I think it's important for
reconciliation and redemption I kept
telling Tommy Blanton that people in
Birmingham as much as they wanted
justice they also wanted to know why
they wanted hear somebody say that they
were sorry and that they they maybe
didn't mean to kill anyone I never got
that from him he's still alive he's
still alive he's in prison the last time
I went was right before his parole
hearing I was thinking that was the
perfect opportunity if he ever wanted to
get a chance because I told him the
first time we met he would die in prison
if he doesn't talk to me and tell the
story and talk about how sorry he is and
give us the whole story they just
wouldn't do it they'd have ice water in
their veins go mm-hmm why was it so
important what was the biggest challenge
in terms of prosecuting them four
decades later what's the most important
thing that everyone has learned in your
revisiting of this the biggest challenge
was just time I mean if people were
dying people were older or they were
forgetting we were trying to pull
together old evidence some new evidence
from admissions I think what people got
it was such a sense of healing you know
I don't use the word closure for these
cases you should never close these cases
we always need to remember but it was
such a healing for my community for
Birmingham for the state and
particularly for these families and
that's that's incredibly important and
that's why I think this new cold-case
bill that that Ted Cruz and I did is
also going to help on that bring these
records to light and let people learn
about there was a lot of determination
going into this there was a lot of
determination unbelievable team that
never gave up never gave up thank you
thank you so much good to see you thank
you I'm bending toward justice goes on
sale tomorrow